the Avengers have fought a lot of bad
guys over the years but despite having a
rogues gallery as long as your arm only
a handful of villains have actually made
their way to the big screen and only one
of them can even be said to truly be an
Avengers villain first and foremost
Ultron first appearing in 1968 Ultron
has been resurrected again and again and
again and again so many times that you'd
need a master's degree in marvel ology
to catalog them all the characters
constant design changes means the
talented people in charge of adapting
him for 2015's Avengers age of Ultron
had their work cut out for them in terms
of coming up with a great cinematic
design fortunately charlie when former
head of visual development at Marvel
Studios was up to the challenge
when sat for an exclusive interview to
go over all the ins and outs of
designing the movie version of the
homicidal robot that Marvel fans loved
to hate when he first appeared in 1968
Avengers number 50 for Ultron didn't
have a name much less any distinct
design the issues story concerns the
Masters of evil teaming up to capture
the Avengers with the help of secrets
provided by the team's Butler Jarvis but
the stories end one of the Masters of
evils newest members the Crimson cowl is
revealed to be an unnamed robot decoy
covering for the cowls true alter-ego
Jarvis the butler then by the next issue
writer and artist Roy Thomas and John
Bousema apparently realized that
suddenly making Jarvis evil for no
actual reason wasn't the best move
instead they made the random robot now
apparently named Ultron 5 the living
automaton the true villain all along who
hypnotized the Avengers faithful Butler
into temporary betrayal even with the
revelation of this new villain named
Ultron five readers still wouldn't learn
much about his actual origins for
several issues specifically Avengers
number 58 there it's revealed that Hank
giant-man Pym was experimenting with
creating synthetic life and built a
goofy robot that looked more like the
clanking boiler you might have in your
basement then the mechanical menace he
become after his initial fight with
giant man Ultron somehow erased his
science daddy's memory and just jumped
through a concrete wall like the
kool-aid man
but with more lasers and inexplicable
memory erasing technology among these
first appearances only a few design
elements managed to stick some swooping
angled lines on Ultron's face that
resemble angry eyebrows some extraneous
metal bits that kind of look like robot
ears and a mouthful of chunky Robo teeth
over time Ultron's defining chompers
somehow morphed into a weird tooth the
grin as a result Ultron looks pretty
well he looks pretty dumb right Marvel
Studios former head of visual
development Charlie when who led the
team responsible for adapting Ultron to
the big screen more or less agreed if
you look at the comic book Ultron he
looks very simple in a head that's
always the feel of it interestingly when
tapped into that idea while creating the
concept art for sequence in the film
after Ultron's coated a new version of
himself in vibranium the reason because
even though Ultron looks simple he also
looks deranged not a quality you want to
shy away from if you want to make your
villain as menacing as possible
we knew that Ultron from Joss Whedon
script at that moment he was sort of
going nuttier even the way he talks
Joss really wanted to get an Ultron that
felt like he wasn't right in the head
that was trying to come up with a look
for that diehard comic-book fans may
have been upset that the classic look
didn't make it into the film on Ultron
Prime however when and his team brought
the old-school comic book Robo grain to
the villains henchmen instead the Ultron
sentries are the villains mechanical
representatives who plagued the Avengers
while they try to save sokovia from
complete annihilation another reason
when saved the classic Ultron face for
the centuries was simple practicality
discussing the classic comic book looked
for Ultron's face when pointed out the
difficulties that would come from trying
to put it on your main bad guy you're
getting many design challenges here you
know one is like how are you gonna
animate that face you're not gonna get a
lot of expression from that either and
he needs to talk he needs to express you
so it's not surprising that the sentries
got the grin rather than Ultron Prime
the Ultron centuries are basically
cannon fodder display
while bad guys the heroes can chew
through while trying to get to the real
villain they didn't need to do much
beyond fight and die meaning that they
were the perfect vehicle for the classic
look when and his team had to find lots
of new angles and explore tons of
different ideas to bring Ultron to the
big screen including a much more human
looking version of the mad robot villain
which is on display in these three
side-by-side images to explain his
approach in these concept art images
when referred back to some of Ultron's
most famous lines from his introduction
in the film character wise he's more of
like a evil pinocchio you know I want to
be alive I want to be a real boy I mean
Ultron wants to be a real person I mean
he's becoming more and more real but
sort of his circuits are messed up you
know things are getting crossed how do
you get that across and his expressions
we knew we needed to have a face that
can have subtle expression we did a lot
of focus on how those plates can move
what what can make it feel like that's
expressing in certain ways and how does
it form there's so much to try to figure
out in that and that's why I took such a
long time ultimately it's pretty tough
to translate a design like Ultron's to
the movies but when work to transform
the character from a goofy comic-book
robot to a dangerously intelligent foe
with that in mind this concept image
clearly communicates the characters
intelligence and lurking Menace I really
liked an elegant version of Ultron I did
some that I felt like we're going more
towards that but then he also needed to
really show sort of a instant power from
you know that the first read we kind of
had something in between somewhat
elegant but also showed enough presence
and power that sums up the balance when
struck in the end a blend of power and
presence that made for one of the most
unforgettable comic book villains to hit
the silver screen Thanos and his fancy
glove may be all the rage these days but
don't forget that Ultron was nearly too
much for the Avengers to handle and he
didn't have a fancy magic glove he could
use to snap himself to victory either
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more exclusive looper
videos with Charlie when about the
creation of the marvels
Mattek universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]